what are your thoughts on obviously the
the exit
in itself was a disaster leaving
afghanistan look but getting out look i
thought i'm not going to lie that you
know afghanistan was a long drawn-out
war america we dumped trillions
trillions of dollars and just just not
if afghanistan but iraq the philippines
the war in africa the war in the middle
you know i mean
you guys are not hearing the wars or
were fighting these secret wars right so
imagine that being dumped so we needed
to get out there but man any any
military guy would tell you there's a
plan withdraw even if an ambush a raid
anything so simplistic like that but
imagine you've been fighting a war for
20 years we own that region
we militarily own that region and when
we started collapsing our forces in did
you know that the taliban took
90 percent of that country already when
they are getting the intelligence and
then they're saying oh it won't collapse
they already knew it's going to collapse
who do you put that on meaning
is it the generals is it actually biden
was it the the agreement that trump did
with the taliban you know
i want to let you know how the the the
rank structure works
right the president is the where the
buck stops but he has his military
advisers the military advisors advise
him on the tactics and the strategy on
how to withdraw it's up to the president
he will listen to it
you know so
i wasn't there i don't know what
conversations are being held but i'm
telling you when i saw how things unfold
on i don't know on on a public
television right i could tell you i can
war gamer from there you should have
closed down all the air bases and go
down condensing only one air base we had
bagram we have all these other air bases
why are you gonna why are you going to
condense all your forces
in one area we know that they the
talibans can control that area so what
i'm saying to you is there was a
strategy just like a strategy in war and
withdrawal
there was no strategy on this withdrawal
and we lost our footing in one of the
most important regions in the world for
america
for not only our safety but for the
growth of america
right economically
we did we we left it and then now we're
legitimizing a a
terrorist
organization we're about to finance them
we're going to finance we're in the
gymnasium we're allowing them to enter
our country
you know so for me look i'm not a
politician man do you feel betrayed at
all as a service member
when you leave our troops
when you leave our troops to die when
you um
you know gosh man i've been in these
countries i've worked as singletons
you know i couldn't imagine being left
overseas serving my country under the
orders that you gave me
you're going to leave us and that's not
the first time this administration did
we did in libya
when when the annex got attacked and the
seals and the cia guys got drug out in
the streets we left the obama
administration yeah right we left them
right hillary
we left them so this administration is
showing that kind of same
lack of support for our our military who
who's ordered to go and fight
for the home for the safety of our
homeland
and what about the border patrol whose
order to protect our borders is now
being scrutinized
right judged off of a photo
off of
off of racism everything is racism
they're going to throw it in your face
you know you got to look at the bigger
picture here
right the bigger picture safety of our
country and the growth of our our
country and how are we going to sustain
you know
to be a superpower
because i tell you man
there's a lot of countries in this world
that wants to take us down
and our military is the only one that's
fighting overseas to safeguard our our
country and that too
you know is is being taken away so if
you enjoyed this little short segment
from the podcast that we did here's
another short segment to watch or if you
want to see the entire podcast click
over here take care everybody bye-bye
[Music]
you